what i want to do in this video is to
give you an intuitive sense of how a how
a a a market for currencies would
actually work and it's it's very
non-intuitive for a lot of people
because we're going to be talking about
currencies becoming more expense or more
expensive or cheaper or the price of a
currency in terms of another one and
what i want to just give you a very
intuitive feel for that so let's say
well just you know because this is on
it's a hot topic right now let's just
make the two currencies the chinese
renminbi
and the us dollar and the unit of
exchange and china is a little confusing
because sometimes they use the word
renminbi sometimes the word wan the wan
is the unit of the renminbi so let's say
right now
let's say right now if i were to just go
on some website and this is not the
actual exchange rate right now but let's
say right now the quoted exchange rate
is 10
10 1
per u.s dollar 10 won is equal to one
one u.s dollar and every time i say
dollar in this video i'm referring to
the us dollar is equal to one u.s dollar
and i think this makes sense to a lot of
people if i have one dollar i want to
convert it to 1
i get 10 of them if i have 10 1 i want
to convert it to dollars someone's going
to give me a dollar for it now let's
imagine a situation and in the next few
videos i'll construct actual trading
trade
imbalances where this would actually
happen
but let's say we
live in a reality where there are one
thousand so let's say you know someone
has a thousand won so let's say that
this person right here
let's say that this person right here
has one thousand one
let me write over here has
has one thousand
one
and wants to convert to dollars
and
wants
to convert
convert
to
dollars
now let's say on this side and if we
just superficially looked at this
thousand won and look at the quoted rate
we'd say hey that thousand one you
divide you get 10 won per dollar so that
should be a hundred dollars at the
quoted rate let's say you have two other
actors over here and obviously these
markets involve many many more than just
three people but this will help us
simplify or at least understand how
these exchange rates would work let's
say that this person right here
let's say that this person right here
with the mustache
let's say this person right over there
and maybe a hat as well
let's say that he has let's say that he
has
let's say that he has
fifty dollars
let me say he has a hundred dollars
has a hundred dollars
as hundred dollars that
that he
needs to
convert
to juan maybe he wants to buy some
chinese goods maybe he's a chinese
factory owner who sold his goods in the
u.s 400 and now he needs to convert it
back to juan to pay his employees or pay
his own mortgage or who knows what and
let's say that there's another person
let's say that there's another character
over here
there's another character over here and
let's say that she also let's say that
she also has
let's say that she also has
let's say that she has a hundred dollars
that
that need
need to be converted
converted
into
one so net net what's happening here
what's the total demand to convert one
into dollars and dollars into one well
if you look at the whole market you have
two hundred dollars that need to be
converted into one so let me write this
down
we have a situation where two hundred
dollars
two hundred dollars
need
to
be converted
into
one
and then to kind of off the the on the
other side of that transaction we have
1001 need to be converted into dollars
so now we have one thousand one
one thousand
one
need
to
be
converted
into
dollars and for simplicity these are the
only actors these this they are
representing the entire market although
as we know the entire you know in
currency markets especially there's
there's
thousands or even millions of actors
actively uh participating in them so
what's going to happen all of these
people might just go on the the internet
and look up the current exchange rate or
the one the the last exchange that
occurred and said hey you know what me
over here this hundred dollars i should
be able to convert it into a thousand
won but she also says i should be able
to convert this hundred dollars into a
thousand one so they collectively think
that that two hundred dollars can be
converted into two thousand won so i'll
put this in question marks so will they
be able to convert this into 2001
into 2001. and on this person over here
you know he's saying well you know just
at the current exchange rate maybe i'll
be able to get maybe i'll be able to get
for my thousand won maybe i'll get a
hundred dollars but everyone wants to
maximize the amount of the other
currency they get for obvious reasons
they want to maximize the amount of
money they get
now will these two people be able to
convert their money into 2001. remember
what i said is this is the entire market
it's a huge simplification but there is
this imbalance here more dollars into
one than one into dollars now they won't
be able to convert into 2001 because
there's only one thousand one that wants
to be traded
there is only one thousand one that
wants to be traded so you can imagine
this guy over here maybe he wants to do
it slowly just to kind of see what the
market is like so let's say his first he
puts let's say he at first he puts 10
one up essentially for bid you could
view it either way you could say that
maybe one of these people put a dollar
up for bid and this guy is bidding on
that dollar in terms of one or this
guy's putting one up for bid and these
guys are going to bid on it in terms of
dollars either one
and that's why it's sometimes confusing
with currencies because you're buying
another currency but since this guy is
in more in demand so this since this guy
is more in demand more
more demand to simplify things i'll make
him the person that's kind of able to
create a an auction type situation which
really what is what the markets are are
trying to do so that you can equalize
supply and demand
so he might put out he might he might
initially say hey you know what i want
to convert
i want to he's going to he has 101 and
he's going he wants to convert it so he
says you know what i'm willing to sell a
hundred won for ten dollars
so let's say he sells 101 for 10
so he sells
100 or offers i should say
offers
offers to sell
for
10 he just thinks that that's a fair
offer price right over there and that's
this guy over here this guy actually
converting one into dollars well what's
going to happen well one of these people
are just going to jump at that they say
oh you know what i think that's a fair
price and so let's say this woman right
over here takes it then actually both of
them maybe have saw that offer to sell
101 for 10 and they both try to click
their mouse or however they're trying to
make the transaction happening but let's
say she clicks her mouse a little faster
and she gets the transaction
so let's say that person let's call this
person
let's call this person b and this is
person a and this is person c
so person b so person b accepts
person
b
accepts
so two things happened just then one is
person c says wow that was pretty fast
someone was very willing to take it for
10 won per us per us dollar and then
this guy goes like my god i need to
convert my money into one but i wasn't
able to someone else beat me to the
punch so this guy over here is not an
idiot he's like hey maybe people are
willing to give me more dollars per one
so let's say that this guy right over
here this guy in orange he then offers
he then offers
offers to sell
to sell
let's say he he wants to sell 91
for
notice the price of the wand has now
gone up or the price of the dollar has
now gone down either one those are the
symmetric statements they mean the exact
same thing
so all of a sudden this person has a lot
of dollars he needs to convert into one
so he accepts really fast so person a
accepts and i'm doing a huge
oversimplification but gives you the
general idea to show you that this
really is a market
so person
person a accepts all of a sudden we have
a new quoted exchange rate we all of a
sudden we have an exchange rate of what
is this nine
so we have new
new quoted rate or the transaction
happens at
nine
ones
nine ones per
per dollar
now what's happening and i think you see
the dynamic that's going to happen
there's more
dollars that need to be converted into
one
than one that needs to be converted to
dollars so this guy as he sees that
there's a lot of demand to get his 1001
he's going to keep offering fewer and
fewer wands per dollar or
these guys are going to keep are going
to start accepting fewer and fewer wands
for each of their dollars so as this
happens as the price of the wand will go
up notice the price of the wand went up
here it was 10 watts per dollar now is 9
watts per dollar or you could say the
price of the dollar has gone down and
this will just keep happening until all
of them are able to get rid of their
currency it's actually it's actually
dependent there's no mathematical
formula to say what the clearing price
is it's actually dependent on how badly
each of these people are willing to
transact and really how good they are at
gaming each other but the general result
here and this is the kind of what i
really want you to get from this video
is that because there's no there's no
law in a in a market exchange rate
mechanism that says this has to be the
exchange rate we'll explore
how you can peg it in the future but
there's nothing that says that this has
to always be the case if there's more
demand for juan than dollars as we see
in this example the price of the dollar
will go down so the price of dollar will
go down
i'll do this in a little price
of dollar
will go down and then which is the exact
same thing which is which means the
exact same thing as the price
price of
one will go up i really want you to
internalize this we'll go
up in terms of dollars price of dollars
in terms of one will go down and this is
this is the crux of foreign exchange if
you can at least internalize these ideas
and to understand that there really is
this market out here based on the supply
and demand of one over here the the
demand for one is exceeding its supply
so price will go up and or you could do
it the other way the demand for dollars
is below its supply so the price will go
down anyway i'll let you think about
that for a little bit in the next video
we're going to apply this concept to see
how this freely floating
exchange rate can help equalize or
should help equalize trade imbalances in
an ideal world